it's garbage if you go to the front line
Ukraine right now you do not see women
in their makeup and their manicures you
see [__] men in the freezing cold
dying you know where the women are Dubai
chilling that's where the women are so
to sit and pretend that women are just
as capable physically as men as a
[__] lies delusion descending your
strongest man is delusion you are good
at all things you're better than men at
a lot of things but it's not the
physical world and the unfortunate
reality about life is what we're saying
when I was saying earlier that feminism
goes out the window when things get hard
the harder the world gets it the closer
it gets to the Baseline of humanity the
unfortunate basement of humanity is
violence that's what happens when of all
the electricity were to go out and all
the police were to quit this would
become a violent place very quickly and
there would be [__] zero feminists
left zero you would all need men that's
the bottom line of reality that's the
bottom line so you have to understand as
a woman and say okay I need a man who's
good at being a man